uh so my talk is on extending Cordo and
we do that qu extensions and uh I just
want to say quter really does a lot like
when I first saw
it I was it was unbelievable that I
could do articles websites blogs books
presentations and even knowledge we
oppose that has a lot end of
itself but also you can make products
that contain computations performed with
python R Julia observable and that's a
lot more that's just quite a
comprehensive package that cor delivers
and now we have extensions or we had
extensions for quite a while and they
really can open up a whole world of
customization
possibilities and there's lots of them I
was really impressed that there's so
many quo extensions they can barely fit
in this slide here and that's only just
small you know portion of them so
there's lots there's a there's
definitely people chopping at the bit to
create extensions for CTO which is
really
impressive uh okay so the big question
is we know there's lots of extensions
where can you find these extensions
where's the best place to sort of get uh
introduced to them okay the place I let
to go always is the c.org
website okay it's a great starting point
for Lots you know of quo things and
really the section you want to go to is
in the top nav
extensions which is just a huge section
in of
itself so in there you'll
find uh just like you know just the
extensions themselves they're broken
down by the type and there's like a
creating extensions uh section which is
also really comprehensive and huge uh
pretty much everything you need to like
learn about extensions in CTO and to be
a user and or a creator of extensions is
all in
there okay uh I'm just going to like
break down the four different types of
extensions in case You' never heard of
them or you just want a little more
explanation so the types of extensions
are uh short Cod SL filter extensions so
with those you modify select parts of a
quoto document and uh and short codes
are a little bit different than filters
short codes have a little syntax I'll
get into that a little bit more later
and filters just sort of automatically
transform sections of sections of your
document um if you're writing an article
for a journal you be happy to know that
uh there's a whole uh world of of
Journal article extensions uh which is
great there's uh a large amount and it's
growing every day uh this is sort of
similar in spirit to the arttic Articles
uh package in R except this is all in
Cordo Uh custom formats uh we saw before
that there's already lots of formats you
can create your own format which is
quite amazing uh so with extensions you
can write your own to create a custom
format which is just unbelievable to me
uh reveal reveal JS um if you're using
reveal JS to create a presentation um
it's great there's extensions that
create themes for these presentations uh
it's really a wonderful section of the
site for this talk I just want to narrow
it down to like one type because this is
so huge uh to one type of extension and
that's the class of short code SL
filter uh extensions and we don't have
much time so I just want to like narrow
it down even further to short code
extensions okay are short C exensions
they act a little bit like
functions um but you don't use them in
computational cells they're they kind of
live in the pros of a document
okay okay and there's a number of
shortcode extensions I want to share
with you there there's so many I like I
just want to narrow it down to just a
few that I really like all of them deal
with icons because I really love
icons okay so this font awesome that's
great can insert all the font awesome
free icons in your document it's almost
like a household name these days font
awesome and there's material icons which
you may not know about so it's good to
have a second set you know mix things up
and now we have another set you can use
in a syntax that's very similar to the
first set all these short codes pretty
much use the same sort of like style for
uh
usage it's also BS icons it's good to
have a third set and you really have
lots of icons as you can see I'm just
obsessed with icons uh but if you one
these BS icons are actually really good
and there's the all important hex icon
there which is could be useful uh so
these are bootstrap
icons okay one more well actually no
more few more but this is one another
academic cons okay so if you're in
Academia this is essentially an icon set
you'll with icons you'll find nowhere
else see El ofe you can sort of see
Springer you're not going to get those
in the other ones so this is pretty much
Essential if you're doing like an
academic website and you want to Pepper
with
icons one more this is a special
one okay I just discovered it Lord icon
get this these icons are animated I
don't know if you can see this if you're
at the back of the room you might want
to stand up cuz look at that that's
Chicago over there a plot that's
actually interesting a check mark that
is dynamic a cat and a boom box these
are animated and you can have all these
and more in your Coral document okay
imagine that you can change the color
you can do all sorts of things
okay you can see why I love icons
there's it's a whole
universe okay so I hope I got you
sufficiently excited about these icons
and how and by extension short codes uh
so if you haven't used them yet uh I'll
show you how to use it so you start by
adding the extension inside the working
directory of a project okay so in the
console you would use quto ad and then
the repo that has the extension the
reason we do that is because we download
the asualt extension it just becomes
like a folder extensions folder and you
essentially commit that when you are
doing like
get so when you run that you'll be
prompted to agree to this install you'll
actually get prompted twice um but it's
in most cases it's good to say
yes and this is how you use it uh in a
Coro document so we have this little bit
of text we need some font awesome icons
here is one and then we have the double
curly braces and then the uh you know
the greater than less than on either
side either side and then all
importantly you have to have a space
right okay then it works then it's fa
and the icon name okay and to find out
what the names are you just go to the
font awesome website there's a great
icon listing just make sure you use a
free icon and it should work
here so yeah what you get in the output
document is that thumbs up icon uh it's
nicely scaled to the text looks really
good it's quite satisfying to to see it
rendered like
that great so short cards they're pretty
easy to use um but they can also offer
more power through arguments so here's
some more examples with the font awesome
extension just to keep it going so you
can do things like you know of course uh
you know just have the icon just give
the name but you can also use size
equals LG to make it large so that's
great uh you can there's different size
classes so just look at the
documentation usually the documentation
for a show code lives on the REM me at
that repo that the shortcut lives on so
all all the instructions are there so
all these things should be explained and
uh and some of them you know some of
these icons uh icon short codes allow
for a title which is great so when you
hover over you can supply a title and
this is also great for accessibility
because a screen reader will read
this okay so yeah so after running all
this we do get that U output right there
so we get the thumbs up the slightly
larger envelope and uh the really sized
up
battery okay just some tips because you
know I know you're going to use this
right away uh around complicated values
given arguments like that battery thing
I would definitely use quotes right
because uh you know L can't really parse
sometimes you know it's is simple then
it's fine like the LG but I would use
quotes just to be safe also uh this is
not surprising but just you know just a
little heads up you don't get
autocomplete for these inside a document
you just have to sort of like not make
mistakes and have to remember things so
don't mess it up so just go to the repo
for guidance uh yeah if you do mess it
up okay so uh where're to find even more
extensions and other Coral resources as
well so this is recommended in last talk
uh the awesome quto on GitHub repo so
that's right there that site uh right
there and this is just a smas board of
like uh resources they're really very
current it says the most upto-date
curate list of cor
dos talks tools example and articles the
internet has to offer it's a bold
statement but it's true it really is the
place to go to yeah and let me show you
it just take you a tour of this giant
like read me there's a section there on
extensions this is the most
comprehensive list I've seen and this is
how I discovered most of those uh icon
short code
extensions okay Journal articles this is
part of that articles thing I talked
about I'm getting a little bit off the
topic of icons but that's okay um you'll
find what available in journal articles
like templates it's all there uh there's
also presentations HTML document
templates PDF documents so many things
even like mixed multiple formats docx
even wow so that's all there awesome
awesome
quto so I was inspired by all this um so
I did a thing I I I like icons a lot
that's obvious by now uh and I enjoy
documentation too I don't know if you
know that about me so I created a repo
full of examples of how to use icons in
CTO okay so I just made this public
today it's pretty good all all it is is
just like a bunch of qds it's got all
the icons S A preload in there I
committed that stuff like the extensions
and you you could just clone this you
know try it out uh render some stuff
change things around uh it's actually
surprisingly hard for some of these
extensions to get them to work right
there's
some uh Missing tips and tricks that I
put in there that that help a lot
especially for the laicon thing I mean
that's pretty valuable you have like
animated icons so you got to know how to
do that right so you can learn about um
how to use all five of those icon based
short code extensions and plus how to
use aify written by the same person who
made the awesome quto uh GitHub repo and
this is just like this blew me away this
has like not thousands of icons tens of
thousands of icons in different
libraries it it's rather nuts it's
rather
nuts okay but it's there it's there in
that
description so at this point you might
be inspired to make your own shortcode
extension you know it's not that it's
not that bad of a thing to do uh there's
already a lot but there aren't nearly
enough that's my opinion of of things so
if you have the need to make one why not
make one yourself okay so if you're
doing that where do you start uh well
the coral website again uh go to that it
has a great section on creating
extensions it's just uh extensions SLC
creating
and not only that you can use other
extensions which are already built as a
model for a shortcut
extension uh like font awesome that
one's incredible uh I just went to the
repo went to the to Lua file and I just
used that to make my own extension it
was
great and then our next speaker actually
wrote that
Carlos oh I'm pretty sure he did
okay he's saying no okay let me show you
that code uh it's inspiring so um I'm
going to do something which is ill
advised show you a bunch of Luba code in
a
talk but don't worry I'm going to zoom
in I just want to show you that all the
main Logic for the font awesome
shortcode filter it fits inside 40 lines
of code like all this value is in 40
lines that's amazing I mean there's like
other functions above but you know don't
worry about that um but all the main
stuff is here 40 lines of code I'm going
to zoom in okay in a sec uh first I want
to tell you that all of logic it's a
been weird the start you you create a
return statement and that's just how it
goes with these
extensions okay and then okay so if you
remember the font aome demonstration use
fa then the name of the of the icon so
you sort of Define a function which is
like fa and then you have typically args
and quars okay uh okay so that's great
it's not that bad so far you make a
function okay and then you have to like
parse your own arguments which is not
too terrible again we have this code
here it's there for posterity it's not
going to change I don't think uh but we
can use this as a guide and we're going
to get like these like uh variables and
we can use that to sort of create like
the icons themselves like create the um
essentially the the bit of like HTML
that gets the
icon and just some nice clues in here uh
that are kind of hard to figure out if
you you're not reading this code you use
things like you would use things like
pandoc util stringify to get the
argument values of strings that's a nice
little trick and you see one and two
that's like just like the ARG
position uh and then if we have things
which are like size that's like ARS
keyword arcs instead of positional
arguments and then you get the values
from the named arguments which is
great and then uh this is like a
pleasure to me like when I started using
Lua it's string concatenation operator
dot dot it's really wonderful it's just
a joy to use you just string together a
bunch of things and it's like paste and
R and it's quite nice to
use okay and another little trick uh
this will be really useful when you make
your own extension which is going to be
pretty soon I'm sure uh when returning
some HTML or latex latch text we need to
typically use uh pandoc raw inline just
remember that and if returning nothing
pandoc null is the thing to
use
okay okay and you might see just in this
little scan of like your first L code
you ever seen probably uh we have helper
functions like is empty that's defined
above the code oh just a show of hands
has anybody ever ridden some Lua in here
ever
oh not bad not bad I saw like maybe 10
people that's
good okay again 40 lines of code nice I
mean not that much we get a lot out of
it I mean now we have font font awesome
icons in in Cordo okay I was inspired by
this all this work I saw on short code
extension so I made my own and I'm
calling a q format and that's been
that's available today so it's at this
site uh not site uh at my GitHub
essentially and it's a formatting
extension for CTO I'm going to show you
that super
briefly it's uh a way to format numbers
right now you give it a number and some
options and it'll nicely format it as a
decimal value as an integer value or
something in scientific notation on that
last point it's actually super hard to
make nice scientific notation without
going nuts uh in uh in CTO it's pretty
manual uh with this you get the right
sort of like uh formatting no matter
whether you're using HTML or lch or PDF
I should say in the end and if this this
thing I hope we'll sort of like uh catch
on and I'm planning on doing more like
say taking numbers and making currency
values out of them or helping with units
notation and making that nicely
formatted and just doing other little
things that you know would be nice for
formatting okay so I'm going to show you
a quick example of this extension uh
since it's so new and uh I would say
good formatting makes for a good
document and that's always true uh
here's some examples so in this uh first
example a floting point number and then
we have the short code and it starts
with Q format and then we have like a
sub command or like a type I'm just
saying num so because I want a number in
the end and we have this pretty big
complicated number with some you know
decimal places so I can just say
decimals four use separators these are
like the uh commas or the grouping
separators I'm just going to say no for
this one okay and in the end at the very
bottom if you scan down yeah has four
decimal places and you know that's
pretty good uh if you have a large
integer that's you know you can express
it as you know a very large thing in
exponential notation it'll just expand
it out and use the separators right
away uh scientific notation you can do
that this is a sort of hard thing um so
that's great you don't have to use like
sup or span if you're doing HTML it just
sort of does that for you which is
good okay so I want to conclude my my
goal in this talk was to convince you
that extensions are cool and extending
quo the name of my talk is a good thing
uh so yeah all those things you get but
having extensions uh you know it just
takes it out this world you can
customize basically anything gives you a
ton of control uh the community has
already made a ton of
extensions and uh so you know the fature
looks pretty bright you know I can
imagine there'll be many more and
they'll get more sophisticated as time
goes on and thanks to the power of Lua
you write the extension code once and
then all these like you know like uh
ways of expressing your computations all
those users benefit so that can only be
a good
thing okay and that's it um I just want
to say that my presentation is at my
personal GitHub under presentations it's
in there and those two things I talked
about that I did uh they're also in my
personal uh GitHub and just want to say
thanks thank you
we have a number of questions for you
first one our packages come from cran
but where do quto extensions come from
are they ratted at all wondering about
corporate policy on installation yeah
it's right now a little bit of a wild
west situation because it just lives in
a GitHub repo it could live in other
repos as well but the sort of default or
the easiest way is GitHub and um and
because of that you know it's a little
bit unsophisticated there's no package
down websites for an extension there's
just like the read me but hope REM me
has everything you need there might be
examples but yeah it's it's pretty much
like not like that at all so use use at
your own risk basically pretty much yeah
yeah second question is kind of a
feature request yeah um can you create
an r package to create extensions so we
don't have to learn Lua
oh maybe not I mean Lu is not that bad
like um I'm going try to disuade the the
person to kind of kind of avoiding the
question though I'm avoiding the
question but I'm giving an alternative
right L is not bad like I I learned it
just by looking at different uh you know
for shortcodes at least at different
code was nice I looked at a YouTube
video or two on on Luba sort of like
helped me out a little bit more uh I'm
I'm just going to say no to the the
question yeah okay next question can you
inject R code or objects into short code
I believe you can use no you cannot do
that no it's Lua all the way down by the
time we get to Lua yeah nther has
already executed is the main issue right
right yeah yeah that's totally
it what Carlo said is no short code but
statement It's Tricky um ask us about it
and we'll try to solve in a one onone
thanks rich thank
[Applause]
you